was clear from tonight's Gathering that
Janae was loved by a lot of people his
family says even though his life was cut
short he used the time he had to make a
difference
in remembrance of uh of our dear brother
and father and
friend candles flicker as so many tears
fall all while dozens gathered to
remember jonain Dominguez still not real
the 43 year old father of nine was
killed Tuesday while working at all in
Towing police say the suspect
27-year-old jatone herder shot him after
an argument over his car and ran off he
later turned himself in I felt an afro
spirit I can feel him jonay's wife
Angela joined family and friends Friday
to honor who he was and everything he
brought to our community he always
started to get home about five and
didn't make it home to about eight
because he was stopping to help
everybody along the way and he also
helped so many through local non-profit
work with friends like John harp and
when he walked in the room he lit the
room up he and everyone here including
those he towed cars with every day say
he made their lives better and can't
imagine a world without him you just got
to ask yourself
why but Angela believes he made the best
of the time he had and she knows jonay's
impact will always live on I'm at peace
with that
that he did everything he wanted to do
now Jatan herder is now facing a charge
of open of open murder rather he is set
to make his next court appearance on
January 17th